l'espèce de de révolte de colère que je
peux avoir
quand je constate une forme de mépris
qui s'affiche de façon ouverte contre
certains et cette espèce de deux façons
de considérer qu' il y a des gens qui
n'auraient pas voix au chapitre qui ne
devraient pas avoir le droit de vote qui
ne sont pas aptes à juger et c'est
quelque chose qui me fout hors de moi et
je vais d'abord les deux les deux sont
en fait totalement lié et c'est ce que
j'essaye d'expliquer dans le livre mais
par exemple au moment de la révolte des
gilet jaune le mépris de classe qui a
surgi de la part de certains
commentateurs étaient d'une violence
absolument dingue et moi dans ces cas là
je veux dire il ya en effet une chose
qui me tim et ris c'est l'idée que telle
personne parce que c'est une mère
célibataire parce que c'est un petit
artisan aurait moins que moi qui suis
agrégée de lettres où ils journalistes
ou d'autres qui sont là au ray - le
droit de de donner son avis de décider
de ce que va être le destin de notre
pays et ça c'est un truc qui me fait
bondir hors c'est de plus en plus
violents et on le voit à chaque élection
on l'a vu au moment du breakbeat c'était
fabuleux quand même d'aller expliquer
que ce sont les moins diplômés qui ont
voté le brésil et que donc il ya
certains qui ont émis cette hypothèse ce
serait bien peut-être de réserver le
vote à ceux qui sont plus diplômés
on est chez les fous
[Musique]